NATHAN TURNED.UT THERE FOR
LEDDY AND MAKAR IS GOING TO HAVD
ANOTHER, AND COLORADO SWEPT ST.
LOUIS IN THE OPENING ROUNDS
AGAINST THE NASHVILL BAD PLAY.
AND NICHUSHKIN GOT THE SHOT
AND NO GOALS IN THE REGULAR
SEASON
THROWN TO THE NET, AND IT IS BED
THE PAINT, AND HE NEVER GETS THE
>> Darren: AND THE TEAM HAD A
DON'T KNOW WHERE THEY ARE GOING.
>> Brendan: LANDESKOG THROWS AN
IS EVEN ,
BUT NOW THE OUTSIDE
NET, AND LANDESKOG MAKES A GOOD
PLAY THERE, AND THEY GO  SKATER
THE BLUES ABLE TO RECOVER
FROM THAT ONE.
>> Brendan: O'REILLY WITH THE A
FOR SAAD, BUT
IN, AND
NOW, KYROU DRAGS IT ANBRINGS IT
UNDERNEATH12.
AND LANDESKOG COULT LATE. E IS
THE NECK AFTER THAT HIT.
>> Brendan: AND FACE-OFF TD Mac